so welcome to our audience here in New
York welcome to our audience in Los
Angeles and to everyone watching this
live stream on Yahoo welcome to you at
home as well from the Directors Guild of
America Theatre here in New York my name
is Eugene Hernandez as I said from the
Film Society of Lincoln Center please
join me in welcoming the cast and crew
from into the woods
and you've obviously some rolls on both
both on stage and in movies can you walk
us through the differences in performing
for the big screen versus the theater
the challenge is always about if you're
not going to sing live if you are going
to sing live and you know in this case
trying to find a balance that made sense
for this movie of if I'm going to be
running up and down the steps of the
palace in a calling out would corset
it's gonna have to be you know something
that's gonna have to be pre-recorded
otherwise it's going to be real breathy
and in cases like that it made sense
because it you know Rob and I could kind
of find the performance and craft the
performance in the studio and make the
decision of the emotional journey that
she takes in the song whereas something
like he's a very nice prince with Emily
you know we're sitting on a rock having
a conversation and there was so much to
discover that it didn't make sense to do
it in the recording studio and it you
know we would have been locked into
these performances and had no freedom to
really look at each other and and you
know be challenged by each other in that
scene and and really go no I'm trying to
understand and I'm trying make you
understand so you know we had a we were
lucky enough to get to do both in in
whatever situation made sense for for
that theme did you know some of these
songs already had or some of them were
talking about sometime you think you
know right you think you know and then
we learned that and then Paul Gemignani
punts it out for you on piano and you
take a big gulp and you sit down in
front of your sheet music and your tape
recorder and you just torture yourself
yeah that's great
I understand that you discovered this
musical through this screen adaptation
Chris surely you know the essential
stories of Cinderella right and Jack and
the Beanstalk but I'm curious to know
what you responded to in this screenplay
and and how it makes how it makes these
fairy tales that we all knew as kids how
it makes them so much more complex the
most resonant thing to it you know I've
heard a lot that in high schools they
only perform the first act of the player
oftentimes just the first act of the
play when things are nice and cozy and
kind of what we know and because in the
second act so much destruction and
mayhem and in life happens you know as
much of what we know life to be and I
thought how interesting that you know
especially in Western cultures things
like death and pain and sorrow and all
these things that we consider to be ugly
and that we don't want to look at or for
boat and are kind of pushed aside yet
they are a part of the cycle of life you
know and I think that there's a
beautiful thing there's something
beautiful about incorporating that into
the story that we tell each other that
these things do happen and to invite
children into what it means to be an
adult human being or just to be a human
being which is there is much joy there's
a much laughter but there's also much
pay too much sorrow but there will
always be hope there's always the choice
to you can always choose to hope and I
think that there's something beautiful
about that and as for my character I
loved just loved his two dimensionality
it's just utter fascination with himself
and I told Rob I would probably would
have done I'm een I would have done just
the opportunity to work with everybody
is so fantastic but there's a moment
before agony when will me and leather
pants are walking together and we get to
the we get to the stream Billy says well
no maiden would run from us and I think
well it one has and there's a camera
somewhere far off to my left and the
Prince looks at the camera I'm like I
just love the idea that he knows
somewhere out there someone is watching
so for all these wonderful people doing
all these complex and in-depth
psychological studies my character is
back but there is that wonderful moment
at the end where Cinderella kind of
forces him to look at himself and to
look at the effect that he may be having
on other people that he is hurting
people by what did this determine drive
to love all things at once and she gets
him to feel this could very
two-dimensional character taking from
the pages of the storybook I like that
into the woods explores the complexity
of our own wishes and dreams perhaps no
more clearly seen than in the story of
this woman who yearns to be a mom what
she'll do to become one and then what
happens in the wake of her suddenly
getting that wish I wonder if you might
reflect on that move in think maybe out
of all of the characters in a way the
Baker's wife is morally the most
questionable um and you sort of
understand it because she is desperate
you know just desperate to be a mother
and it's she's worked herself into a
complete frenzy and distraction that she
cannot put one foot in front of the
other until she becomes a mother
it's just that inability to see anything
else other than the desire to be a
mother and and she screws over all these
poor fairytale characters you know and
she takes and takes and takes and does
it with humor and and but she's very
deliberate and is definitely the one who
is prepared to go to any length out of
the couple she's the one who's prepared
to go to any lengths in order to get
what she wants
and she does that and then I think what
happens in the second act when she
becomes a mother which is so joyful and
amazing is that she has to suffer the
ramifications of the morally
questionable things that she's done and
ultimately you know the dalliance with
the Prince and all of that is however
exciting you know
that song moments in the words of the
song of great conflict that's the only
bit of the film which i think is
unbelievable yeah you know like and I
have this I have this with Rob and I you
know I I think I said to him I think
people will believe Giants and witches
beanstalks
Johnny Depp's a wolf no one unknown you
backed me up no one no one leaves this I
think it's actually the tragedy of the
character at the end is that yeah once
she's had this fling with the prince and
is in great conflict about it and is
debating what she did and she shouldn't
have done it but it was good I think
about oh my god I shouldn't have done it
and she realized it's too late and
that's the tragedy I think a lot of
people can relate to that that regretful
feeling and Life offers you sometimes
share with us a little bit of the
experience of shooting this movie tell
us something about shooting on the set
sure but a bit of an experience I give
you a chance to embarrass yourself or
one of your fellow well performers and
tell us about working with the kids
actually as well - before you know it
you're in a room just talking to Meryl
Streep like this is something that you
do and then she's amazing and she sort
of knows how you feel when you come in
when she walked in a room and she does
everything she can to go we're a company
and she led this company from the front
and there is nothing you can say about
her that that hasn't been said as a
performer as an actor it's incredible
but as a person to meet someone who
takes the work so seriously is
meticulous about the work reading it
rereading it doing it it's so serious
about it as a piece and yet takes
herself not seriously one bit makes the
whole experience so much fun what was
the funniest or most memorable moment on
set other than working with this guy day
two we were rehearsing in this mock-up
bakery The Witches entrance into the
bakery and the witch's wrap and
and Merrill's doing the same she's got
the stress you're the SIL rehearsal
dress on us can't you he's like a star
like a big walking stick thing and we're
just playing around with it and she's
doing you know the green screen nothing
and she's jumping all over she's she's
leaping on stuff and jumping up on
things and coming up and getting in your
face and also there's this annum and she
leaps up onto the table day to 11:00
a.m.
leaps volts if you will on to this table
catches her shoe in the dress and starts
to fall back head the tables this high
fall back headfirst towards this stone
floor and time slowed down and I thought
I'm about to watch Meryl Streep die
it's happening I wish I could say I
didn't consider my own career in this
and think this films going to go down
Rob Marshall freezes and he's going oh
my god
Meryl Streep is going to die the person
who stepped in and saved her life that
day was the not the two men in the room
was the pregnant woman leaps forward
catches most rhenium Robert just like
yeah I never I never forgot it really
and I would every day I would look and
take shaken is she gonna really keep
going for it at this level and she
really did
most times I think you only enjoy stuff
on reflection you look back and go god
we really had a great time there I
didn't realize and every day every
single day on this I thought I don't
want this to end
and I know that this is this has
enriched me as a person as a as a
performer and it was the single greatest
time I've ever had on a film set among
the strongest themes of into the woods
is this relationship between parents and
children how do you think kids will
respond to into the woods I think
children of all ages as they used to say
will respond to this because it's it's
deep and joyful and scary and funny
thanks to Chris and his hair really
the world is dark and full of joy both
and they know that they know that from
the time they're very little I was
thinking about my son who used to draw
monsters all the time and I think why
doesn't he draw the lake and the island
it's so beautiful out there and my
garden you know and he always drawing
things that were terrifying because they
have to get ready they have to get ready
in them in themselves they know if be
ready for the bad stuff big stuff
stuff's going to come the role of the
quote/unquote wicked stepmother is
certainly such an iconic character type
in stories right so I'm wondering what
your take on this role of James Lepine
and Stephen Sondheim's stepmother and
and what did you aim to bring to it
having knowledge of how it looked and
felt in the theater and and being asked
to and have it this character the energy
of those characters particularly the
mother is in you know status and money
and image and in that regard I think
she's very contemporary Sensibility the
worst of our contemporary sensibility
could you please talk about the idea of
what a fairytale means to you and and
maybe explain this sort of relevance
importance today as you see it I do feel
this is very much a fairy tale for the
post 9/11 generation I have to say and I
don't think I ever shared this with you
but I was it was 2011 I was listening to
President Obama speak to the families of
the victims on the 10th anniversary of
9/11 and it was incredibly moving and he
was incredibly compassionate and he said
to the families he said you were not
alone no one is alone he said those
words and I remember hearing that and I
thought it's such an important message
for today and it's obviously sort of the
main to me
the main song and the piece and into the
woods and I felt this might be the time
for kids of today families of today to
be able to hear that there is some hope
in the world and it was then that I
called you and said you know could we do
this because I felt like and I still
feel that you know kids today live in a
much more unstable and fragile world
than when I certainly grew up and I feel
like there needs to be something to hold
on to something for them to understand
that it's okay
when something happens disappointing
some loss I mean this this movie has so
many themes it's so beautiful about it I
don't think you set out to do that
originally James sort of thematically
one theme but the theme of loss and how
you move forward is the one that really
struck me talked about this notion of
the woods how you interpret this idea of
the woods how did you think about it and
how did you talk about it with James
well the woods is so many things it's
the place you go into to learn to get
your wish to grow to change its fearful
its seductive it's all of those things
and it's life you know so you you go in
and you learn and come out again a
different person and every character
goes into the woods to get something I
love the desperation that everybody has
needs something so badly and then once
they have that it is it what they wanted
Cinderella's mother in the tree says
that beautiful thing are you certain
what you wish is what you want and it
you think it is but with Cinderella
France and she realizes maybe it's not
where she's comfortable and where she
should be so it's you know it really
explores the woods it's all of those
things that you and it's a it's a
metaphor for life really I'm curious how
far into the process were you trying to
make the decision of okay this is where
we want to go with something practical
have them on location have them singing
and dancing in the middle of a river
versus let's put it in a blue screen and
we'll decide that later on to compute
I think it's very important in this
piece that you really care about these
people I mean what I loved about these
extraordinary actors is that they
brought them to life with such
vulnerability and and strength and and
joy and and and fear and all of it very
human and you know and I think of
Merrill's which for instance it's it's
it's so dimensional in a way that I've
never seen before so vulnerable you care
so much for the witch so that's
important and and that reality and that
be able to be able to touch that was
important for me too and I and so to do
that in a Blue Room or a green room you
know I don't think we would have found
our world take a moment and tell us from
your vantage point as the co-creator of
what we've just seen originator why do
you feel that into the woods remain so
resonant to audiences today what do you
think it is about it that that connects
with people today first of all fairy
tales have been around for a while and
will continue to be so and I think it's
funny how you know I won't bore you with
all the details how we came up with this
notion but I remember I was about to be
a father and my wife was expecting and I
was a little nervous to say the least
and we had just sort of hit on this idea
and I remember I was working on a show
and I was in the theater with the
designer who had a little two-year-old
who she was trying to feed and the kid
was like throwing Cheerios and food all
over the place and I'm going oh my god
what I had to look forward to and I said
you're going to teach your daughter
table manners you know
and she turned to me and said James all
I hope to do in life is teach my
daughter the difference between right
and wrong and it was such a resonant
little moment that it kind of fed our
are a whole sort of thematic propulsion
with with the the writing of the show
and I think it's I don't think we would
have guessed it would be continue to be
this popular but I think it just
resonates because people are always
having children and our children are
growing up and we're leaving them a
world that often more times than not
worries us a lot and we own that you
know once we get older we have to look
back and go where on the other side.now
can't blame our parents you know our
kids are blaming us so that was kind of
the sort of thematic germ of it all
wondering if you could talk about the
process of deciding which songs to cut
and how you made those choices and how
painful was it Rob and I worked really
hard to capture the essence of the show
without ever being literal to it and I
think we both had to come down to the
hard choices what should stay and what
shouldn't and Stephen Sondheim couldn't
have been more supportive of the
decisions there's one person who's who's
missing from this stage but he won't be
missing for long because he sent a note
yes Steve Steve Sondheim is sent a note
he said I'm sorry not to be there with
all of you to celebrate into the woods
but I've been laid low by a virus
however James Lepine my good friend and
collaborator for 30 years
with whom I wrote the show is present to
help convey the pride we feel in the
movie that the Disney studio has made of
it stage and screen are such a totally
different medium the Disney film of into
the woods is a happy exception partly
because so many of the cast come from
the stage this is true and understand
the differences between the two mediums
and hardly because Rob Marshall the
director is an accomplished and imagined
practitioner of both another reason I
have to add blushingly is that James and
I were closely involved in the making of
the movie all along the way from
conception to refinement it was an
exhilarating and exciting experience
which i think is reflected in the final
result I hope you'll agree from Steve
you